Nó này mù sao tháng 12,000 năm 2020, tượng tướng với văn lòng, tướng bộ công an có thương
phân bự dưới chiến công đặc biệt xuất sắc của cuộc kánh rất hiện sự.
Bây triển việc qua học hình sự, công an tình đồng này và công an thành phố chiming,
cơ đơn vị, địa phương đạo phối hợp, nhưng trong bác sự đời tượng mang động
liều lĩnh dùng xuống sách hại bàn người trong bộ gia đình tại sả đất nhau, tình đồng này.
Lỗi dung thương phân như gió. Lấy đạo bộ công an nhận được bảo cáo,
như đồng hài tháng 12 năm, tại thu hợp xấu, xả đất nhau, tình đồng này sẽ giá của an tình trước đặc biệt nghiêm
trong lối tượng mang động, liều lĩnh dùng xuống sách hại bàn người trong cộng bộ gia đình,
cứ tài sản, người hoặc mang, phân lộ trong sự lượng nhân dần.
Bởi tình thân chắc nhận, quyết thâm cao độ và sự phối hợp,
hiện đồng chặt chẽ của công an cơ đơn vị.
Điều phương, sau hơn 2 ngày từ khi tiếp nhận tình bảo,
mặc dù thông tin từ hiện trường phục vụ hợp đồng đuổi trà rất thản chế,
các lượng tục công an tình đồng này, công an tình phố chiming với hợp cuộc cảnh rất hình sự,
về khoa hợp viên sự hình sự hình trường tổ chức đuổi trà,
đến 18 năm, giữa 18 năm tảng hội năm 2018, đá bắt sự đường đối tượng gái an,
tu dữ sống cùng nhiều và chính của của an.
Đây là chính công đặc biệt xuất sách, thiệt sự quyết thâm, trên hiện cao,
mưa chỉ, sáng tạo và rất bệnh về nghiệp của cuộc công an tình đồng này.
công an tình phố chiming, cuộc cảnh rất hình sự, về khoa hợp viên sự trong phố hợp chiến 2 thực hiện chỉ đạo của đăng ui công an chú,
lấy đạo bộ công an. Khi kỏa đưa trà, tham phá của an đã có phần dân đây, phòng người tối phạc
or định tình hiện gái an, nhìn chật tự, cùng của nguyễm tiên của nhân dân đối với lượng công an,
có phần trà mừng thành công của đại hội đạo bộ công an chú người lần thứ 3.
Cái mặt đảng ui công an chú, lấy đạo bộ công an, tôi chúc mừng và biểu dương thình tích xuất sách của các đồng chi.
Đến nghĩ công an tình đồng này, hình chương của cố tài liệu, chính cứ phố hợp với các cuộc quan tình hành tổ tổ tổ xử liên nghiệm đối tượng,
đảng bảo tình như mình của phát lợp. Mong các đồng chi phát viết kích quả đặt được,
tức tục lập như chiến công suất sách hương nữa của phần làm giám tội phạc.
Tưởng bức sế dựa sử dụng sở hội an toàn, lạnh mạnh, viết an ninh tổ quốc, viết cuộc sống mình ý và anh pu cố nhìn dân.